I just called Alfonso
wheel to transfer already miña personal congratulations
and D.O.
Socialist Party of Galicia,
in oseo set by the majority achieved
by the popular party in these elections.
We socialists are democrats
and we accept without reservation or mandate of asurnas.
Hey,
let's not activate
or results we liked,
Huh?
I must say it like this,
without palliatives.
Well,
its main task
was to imply importance
of these elections for the future of Galicia
and in need of 1 change
in 1,
we get.
We did not get it
for the time being,
because a Galician citizen placed about 1 opposition,
now from 1,
oso commitment absolutely
unwavering with Galicia.
As they often say,
we need to consolidate 1 project,
that it is recognized
among citizens
and make it 1 real real alternative.
It is safe
which is undoubtedly an atemonomedo socialist party